slow jams is a record that i distinctly
remember
like being in high school and and that
being like
my favorite record you know that was a
record that was
it was early kanye as far as you know
that was like one of kanye's early
earliest records yeah i feel like it was
like through the wire and then that came
and and i just kind of added to his
allure and that was really
that was really like was that like your
first hit record as far as like radio
like solo
radio level yeah yeah that was that was
like the biggest record of my career
hands down yeah overnight celebrity was
nice too though
man that was that was the joint you know
that was something to have to come with
yeah after the whole the vibe of that
you know so i
i got lucky being able to come with that
one and him
going as hard on the beat as he was able
to oh that bit was crazy now but slow
jams tell us about that record how was
it made like what were the origins of
that record like
like like slow jams was something that
was a vibe that uh
yay already had he already just just had
the whole
aura of it he had the beat he had an
idea of what he wanted me to do
so you know me obviously knowing what
i'm hearing is like
like dope as hell you know not not
knowing it was gonna be
that [ __ ] big but i'm not i'm like
man i gotta body this
so i'm doing my thing on it but then he
put jamie on it and the way it all came
together
and that was like right that was like
peak jamie as an artist too
or really i feel like that is what
really kind of kicked off people taking
jamie serious as a singer
yeah it was that song that song was was
because that was before unpredictable
that was before that his album so that
was like the very first time that we
were like
oh jamie foxx could sing yeah that's
what turned it on to me
for his music career he always was
talented doing music of course
of course that record coming out like
turned it on and launched that
opportunity
and you say jay called that record he
called it up he knew it was gonna be a
hit
he called it yeah